I learned the ingredients to the perfect
burrito as you know the crew has been
working hard all week Ren and Sam just
finished anime self-driving cars Sam
just had a baby everything's going good
so I'd like to do something special
today I'm gonna go out I'm gonna make
the boys my famous breakfast burritos
now here's the thing about these
breakfast burritos they're not just any
breakfast burritos meaning everyone in
your life who eats them will believe
that they're world-famous because that's
how good they are does that make sense
no I don't know it doesn't matter the
point is I'm gonna show you how to do it
well how do I know how to do this well
when I first moved to California I
worked in a Mexican restaurant as a cook
and I learned the ingredients to the
perfect burrito if you've been watching
the channel for a while you might also
remember that I had a 1967 Ford f100
that I was having worked on and it's
done
[Music]
rebuilt the engine rebuilt the third
member in the back and the rear axle put
positive traction and it disc brakes in
the front power steering done all kinds
of nonsense but basically this motor is
the same original casting it's a Ford
390 a 71 motor we don't exactly know
what vehicle it came out of and we
basically took out all the old parts put
all new parts in it replace all the
gaskets included a brand new aluminum
Edelbrock intake what does that do it
makes it beautiful and it makes it run
really cleanly and smoothly I do like
the inside of these doors though but if
you need to work on the door use to take
off that panel that's the night that's
the that's the nice thing about old cars
is that they were so simple
I mean simplicity comes with limitations
acknowledged check but it also comes
with freedoms I still have to I need to
put new wheels on it I need to give them
the new paint job and then I need to
restore the interior so to do that it's
gonna be like another yeah not gonna do
that now but in time that's what that's
where I want to go with it
so it kind of drives like a crown
my favorite features of the old Ford's
is the corner window air conditioning
and it's kind of a sleeper and it runs
really smoothly but it has its own it
has monster torque
it's got palsy traction so
you know we're here to get the
ingredients for the world famous
breakfast burritos and as I go through
and purchase some I'll tell you guys
what's in the recipe first things first
we need eggs he is bigger the better
when it comes to tortillas selection of
bacon is au is critical and the cheese
they have like the American version of
the Mexican and three cheese but if you
can find it finding some like queso
fresco so it comes in these blocks and
then you just break it up a little bit
and you mix it in there it's really good
I'm gonna take all these ingredients
home with me a video with a budget and
the only constraints are is that they
want us to have this band we have a van
that we're working out we have access to
Spencer's desert house that's kind of
where things are at I wanted to have
this meeting so that we could go over a
more in-depth creative course talk about
like who's gonna be in it and just all
the stuff how we're gonna go about
making it given how branded videos have
been performing over the last few months
here I think it's just really important
to make sure we we do it the way we do
any other video and keep the
collaborative and keep it fun and not
like just throw it into the assembly
line I agree it needs to be a good video
it should have some something the only
constraints are they want the van they
want the miramar map and they would like
it to show someone inside of a vehicle
shooting out of the vehicle it's easy
yeah outside of the constraints and
maybe have an event in it the doors wide
open for us kind of doing everyone
there's no reason for us to concern
ourselves from making a video that's
some part what we would make if we
didn't have any constraints because the
constraints are so minor here exactly
and I think I think it's I think it's
really just the main thing right now
where I'm seeing like there's a good
foundation you know just a setup
you know those characters Jeff bands
what are the pub G vigils like that go
above and beyond just like the van that
obviously we're dealing with the force
field which is a big part of the video
but like really like honing in on what
are the best gags we could do you have
this segment was over it's actually just
starting time to make the burritos it's
a lot of food just like in life the key
to success is 99% preparation and about
1% luck we're gonna prepare everything
make sure it's all nice and set out and
ready to go when we need it and then
we'll hold for a little bit of luck from
Dobby and we'll be we'll be tasting
[Music]
smell that hmm first of all when you mix
your eggs mix everything together first
now another key ingredient that people
don't know about cumin do people freak
out they're like what is this it's so
good why is this so good just just a
dash of curry powder dip out the green
chilies you know you get a couple good
ones in there and then you really it's
really about the juice he's hoping this
would be more tomato roasted salsa all
right ten minutes and he just mix we're
whisking key here is to think of light
and fluffy never start your eggs before
you start your bacon all right now let's
turn this up to about a medium now for
the eggs we flip the bacon and as the
eggs are coming to be done we put cheese
in there you prepare the tortillas ooh
what's my favorite type of breakfast a
breakfast burrito obviously he gets me
burritos are great because they have all
the breakfast things in one package easy
to digest mentally and physically it's
I'm super excited breakfast is actually
my favorite meal of the day
any time of the day bacon eggs tortillas
sounds like a perfect combination to me
yo what's up me too
okay that's cool I'll eat it try to eat
it
Jake I don't think knows this I I can
barely stand eggs for some reason the
taste of eggs just like twists my
stomach so I'm a little
hesitant no man that's what I said do
you like eggs a lot of people don't know
how to write good might seeds because
they don't know how they work from a
story standpoint and what makes these
both the one on the hill of Timmy and
Allah and the one the band good is
they're coming at just the perfect
moment in the story you we are hearing
the climax of our story and then the
fight scene happens at the peak of that
mountain regardless of how good the
fights it is that's what makes a good
fight scene at the end of the day it's
like the function deserts so there's
that but then yeah the visual spectacle
and all stuff is in a big part of it
competent filmmakers all right we were
good with the camera we're good with our
narrative so we check that out we're
gonna make the assumption that we've
made it that far
now we're at the next assumption which
is we're competent fight choreographers
all right and I would be bold enough to
say let's check that off as well but I
can name other competent filmmakers and
I can all but name other competent fight
choreographers potentially ones are even
more competent so how do we then take
all that and take one step above that
and that's that's like we're in a really
good clever story around it that takes
places that we've our team is I'm
talking about like doing something
visual like we don't need to solve right
now but I'm talking about like doing a
weird composite trick to make it look
like someone's neck it's broken and it's
like really holding or like doing a fun
trick where we maybe take a helmet and
split it in half a little bit and we
have a cool shot where you take the
panty book but woman you see it's a
person's like helmet but you shouldn't
break off their head and like start like
getting into like these things that that
looks physically impossible unless you
actually smash someone's face in with a
pan okay let's come with a good visual
trick so well I mean it's unfortunately
it's we're dealing with a pan fight
scene that's like literally one of the
most brutal ways to kill someone so we
have to kind of just play that up a
little bit with whether it's face
smashing or neck breaking or helmets
need to get on living so hard it goes
into a skull and it's
fiendish sectors head for a second feet
of dodging things back up we're doing a
thing where we have a guy and we just
bunk and you see his head going again
and the helmet breaks it doesn't even
have to be gory or specific like that's
the what I'm thinking about here like
giving people shots that are difficult
to do they require filmmaking
they require storytelling they require
fight choreography require a little bit
of the effects and then just straight up
a little bit of clever
like that'sthat's what I'm thinking here
cool don't they keep these up in the
microwave to make them nice and soft but
you can't do more than two a time
because otherwise they won't heat up
correct
all right who's first it smells so good
you got to do it fast while they build a
bacon still hot boom little Mexican sour
cream you want bacon yep all right
little bit of ham a little bit of bacon
my wrist where you serve the lighter it
will get so just keep serving this good
call Danny
all right now last step you have to roll
the burrito properly if you don't roll a
burrito properties in there but she did
the cheese is already in there oh she's
hurt in there already in there yeah
what's the first step to a good burrito
roll I see you doing this flattening key
to a good burrito roll first and
foremost you make sure that everything
that's long is going the long way then
you take the sides bring them into the
center and then you spread your fingers
out and mash it so that the whole
burrito is full then around tuck under
and then roll to fit
and it's so tight it's one tight ass
burrito this is really good Jake or your
mom or just have a bomb-ass breakfast
burrito just watch this video yeah show
her this video of us eating burritos
that'll really impress your girlfriend
no just then you'll know how to make it
all right yeah okay man burrito dunk mmm
the bacon is a great touch in the walk
I'm probably gonna throw the rest of
this away it's so good it's also brings
here acidity the guacamole a sour cream
booze limited sweetness they can bring
some crunch which is a nice little
texture on all solid and cilantro in
there I think it tastes like
deliciousness
what's the breakfast burrito invented in
Mexico what are they they're our tex-mex
no Sam Sam ordered some lenses so check
this out yeah yeah look so we so with
the full set here let me let me just dab
them the full set came in from Russia we
started with the 50 here which is great
nice and crisp and clean and clear we
followed it up with a 37 mils and then
the other prized gem which is the 85
Mikami trio Stalin Lenin and Marx 95 55
37 okay so that's basically enough to
give you some real variety there you
could shoot a whole video with these
three lenses and keep it uniform and
style however they use an m40 to mount
which is not what we use we use a canon
mount for the red so we have to use
adapters to get these to work so amazon
amazon guarantees i see it i see a thing
from the guarantee man let's see the
guarantee let's see the Garon give me
the guarantee they proceed to checkout I
got my extra adapters a guarantee I'm
using that payment method
in Tarantino's xxx 20-year indeed that's
Monday that's a guarantee that means if
it doesn't happen we get our money back
guarantee two days shipping to this
place is literally out in the middle of
nowhere let me let me show you where
this place is they're guaranteeing a
two-day shipping to here so this is
where we're filming alright ready let me
zoom out let's keep zooming out until we
reach once if someone spots civilization
let me know find it out all right oh
that would by the way you're still there
and and civilization well naturally it
shall eventually appear oh wait no
that's not what's that that civilization
but somewhere on 70 miles as the crow
flies
guaranteed new day shipping so some some
poor innocent unknowing Amazon delivery
contractor is gonna get this package and
they're gonna have to make the decision
as to whether or not they want to drive
a hundred miles one way to drop off a
package that's this big and return my
goodness well I sure hope they make it
in time yeah that's stuff on Monday we
sure could use it I know I'll bet you
two two one two one
yeah that means if it if it arrives I
owe you 20 if it doesn't arrive on or
before the 30th and you owe me ten mmm
that's an offer that's enough okay I'll
take two-to-one odds on that all right
there you go